diplomats from ukraine and russia are in
turkey this morning for a new round of
peace talks the kremlin says they may
start tomorrow fighting continued
through the weekend with russia focusing
most on capturing territory in eastern
ukraine including the devastated city of
mariupo deborah patta spoke to refugees
from that city she's in the capital kiev
where ukraine's president sent a message
to russia through the media deborah good
morning
good morning in an unusual interview
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
spoke to four prominent russian
journalists detailing the horrors of the
war being waged in his country the
kremlin of course promptly banned it but
it was broadcast outside the country now
given what we have seen on the ground it
is no wonder russia did not want it
aired there
plumes of black smoke choked the sky
after a russian cruise missile plowed
into a fuel depot in lev
firefighters battled for 12 hours to put
out the blaze
around kiev fighting and bombings have
intensified leaving behind
battle-scarred landscapes
but it's mario paul where apocalyptic
scenes show the real extent of the human
toll of this war
valentino was born in this house married
and had children there a lifetime of
memories reduced to rubble
what is left for us she sobs there's no
way to live here now
alexander also stayed and is just
grateful to be alive
i survived he says breaking down crying
as he sends a message to his daughter
thank god your dad is alive
she pains victoria mendinska remained in
mario paul for three weeks before
finally making the death-defying car
trip out of there escaping to the town
of bravery
the street where she lived now looks
like this it must have been terrifying
yes and i cried
because
it's
it's hard to speak
victoria's daughter masha remembers
everything
were you scared
her school was bombed her childhood
blown up
one year ago she celebrated her birthday
surrounded by laughter
i had so many friends she said and now i
have no friends
on sunday a very different celebration
masha turned seven no longer a carefree
school girl but one of the four million
children displaced by this war
a humanitarian corridor was opened up
briefly yesterday allowing the
evacuation of just over 500 people from
maripo but officials say they are still
over
fifty thousand trapped there and they
are running very low on food vlad
all right deborah pada and key for us
deborah thank you very much